it's amazing you know when when you find
your person and your best friend
in this world are you ready to make her
a paw officially
we're getting there
it's obviously the big rematch between
you and tyron woodley but i know it
wasn't originally planned that way tell
me what made tyron the perfect opponent
to replace tommy fury
you know his willingness to step up
first and foremost and have the balls to
step in on on late notice
and obviously a lot of people wanted to
see the rematch he did get the tattoo
and it was a massive pay-per-view event
the first time and so it's gonna be even
bigger this time the vibes leading up to
this fight you seem like ready to go
confident and you're enjoying yourself i
mean from jumping in the pool after that
media workout
there you go
[Music]
now to you singing in the rain olivia
rodriguez good for you
you seem like you're in good spirits
brother how are you feeling going into
saturday
i'm feeling the best i've ever felt
going into a fight you know for me the
last fight it answered a lot of the
unanswered questions that i even had
about myself
and now i have that experience under my
belt
i'm better than ever and had an amazing
training camp switched up a lot of
things i'm 10 pounds lighter brought in
a nutritionist so just everything is
better men's zen mode kill mode ready to
go now what are the chances that you'll
be walking out to an olivia rodrigo song
come saturday
so
that was part of the discussion for sure
it was i really i really wanted to but i
found i found my walkout song that i'll
i'll use from now on in the future
um so
i had to go with that one are you out
doing your brother who walked out to the
greater showmen during that mayweather
fight it has a similar vibe speaking of
olivia rodrigo i didn't realize that you
guys were co-stars back in the day on
disney channel until she said that you
were one of the first people to kind of
spot her pop superstar potential i mean
what was it about olivia that you knew
she was destined for a huge music career
man
you know i would be in my dressing room
and she would be in hers and i would
just hear her singing from down the hall
playing the piano and she was just
always super talented super nice she was
an amazing actor everyone on that set
and that show was super talented but
olivia just had something special and
i'm good at spotting talent it's what i
did with team 10
that's what i'm starting to do with with
boxing now
and so i just know a star when i see and
i told her i was like yo i'm going to
brag about knowing you one day
i guess that day has come full circle
that's so awesome and now she's
nominated for all these grammys she's
about to go on tour i feel like you guys
need to reunite backstage at one of her
shows i'm just saying i hope she can
walk me out to one of my fights one day
i know you posted on instagram that
you're fighting for a few people uh one
of them being your girlfriend julia who
i will say has been gassing you up
leading up to the fight what has it
meant to have her by your side and also
have her support
you know it's amazing you know when when
you find
your person and your best friend
in this world and
she's just so sweet so caring and
she's very supportive she's a part of
this team you know she's an important
part of the team and she's always there
for me whenever i need her and having
someone like that's a such a blessing i
know she recently added your last name
to her instagram handle i mean look are
you ready to make her a paw officially
we're getting there
we are we are getting there um
you know i think we both want to take
that next step we both want to have kids
so uh
man we'll see what happens after all
these fights i will say it'll be pretty
epic if you walk away with a big w on
saturday and an engagement i'm just
gonna put it on the world
that would be crazy
you know you also said that this fight
is for influencers who always get told
no in this world you know what did you
mean by that and have you felt like over
the years that there were some doors
maybe closed on you
yeah this is like an important one for
me so many
influencers like tick-tockers youtubers
we get labeled into a box and people
don't
think we can do anything outside that
box they don't think you're talented
they don't think uh you can accomplish
anything and if you try to go into a
different vertical all of a sudden
you're criticized
so i want to be the example for
influencers tick talkers youtubers that
don't take no for an answer you can go
into wherever it is that you want to go
and work hard and accomplish whatever it
is that that you want
and i i'm i'm the prime example of that
because coming into this
as a youtuber coming into professional
boxing they're saying oh he's a youtuber
he's a youtuber we don't we're not
taking him seriously well what if i was
what if i was just uh a landscaper and i
wanted a box no one would say oh he was
a landscaper you couldn't buy so why is
it that since i'm a youtuber
i can't box and that's just the point
i'm trying to
show people
you